hello everyone I hope you're all having
an excellent Friday and if by any chance
you're not then surely this game will
improve it it's again from round six of
2013 candidates tournament and it's
played between Peter Svidler and Magnus
Carlsen and we do have some photos to
show you after the game and a very
interesting the statistics after the
game so let's let's check out some
photos here we have a photo of sweedler
and Carlson from this game and also we
have a nice photo from swindler it seems
like someone is talking to him during
the game which I'm sure it's really
really not the case but it really
appears that way
so those those are the first we have
from this round and now let's see the
game the game is a closed rule opus but
it's very interesting how the game
develops but you'll see what I mean by
this we have E 4 s wheeler opens with e4
e5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop
to b5 so the rural opus is on the board
a six more fees defense Bishop to a4
Knight to f6
we have castles Bishop to e7 d3 b5
kicking Bishop Bishop to b3 b6 and a4
now cross in place before we have a
knight to d2 castles a5 Bishop to e6 and
now Knight to c4 also you could you
could actually capture here or or even
allow black to capture your Bishop the
night will be very nice and b3 but as
little goes for the immediate nice to
see for rook to b8 we have C 3 we have
captures captures and now h6 rook to e1
and the Queen to c8 quinta c8 where
ideas of Bishop may be coming to g4
later but also if whitey decides to push
h3 then maybe Bishop captures on h3 will
also be an idea
Bishop to C 2 and this Bishop to c2 is
something something new in this position
and it's something that sailor decided
to experiment during the game and after
he was after the game he said that it's
it's not really not really what he was
going for
maybe an earlier h3 would have been
better here cousin goes rook to d8 Queen
to e2 and gush of to f8 Carson doesn't
bother with Bishop captures on c4 it
seems like an automatic why not capture
this night it's a very nice night
you completely ruin a White's pawn
structure but if if you do play this
then the C point and Epona really really
have a nice control on d5 Carson will
never be able to pull d5 and Carson did
give up the bishops pair so he didn't
really gain all that much and if you see
Carson's games then you will you will
often see that Carson has no problems
with double points he often uses this to
his advantage and this is one such
position so rush up to f8 we have 90 to
e3 and now d5e capture some d5 of course
you don't want to allow D for D for with
completely crammed White's position if
you play something slow like h3 then
after d4 captures captures don't really
have a lot of great squares for this
night tonight to f1 and now this bishop
is really really a pawn and it's it's
really a cramped in position for white
so after d5e captures on d5 Knight
captures Knight characters and rook
captures and h3 Bishop to a5 now Carson
will pile up all of his pieces to attack
the d3 pawn as it's a weak backwards
pawn it can never really go to d4 so
rook to d1 starting to defend the D pawn
queen to e6 and now Bishop the b1 Bishop
to B 1 preparing ideas like Bishop to a2
but another thing this bishop to be one
does and which Carson very nicely takes
advantage of is after us wheeler even
develops the dark square bishop the
rooks will no longer be be connected so
Queen to d7 piling up even further
around the D pawn Bishop to e3 and now
efore
and now you see the problem the bishop
on b1 the rooks are no longer connected
so you cannot you can never capture here
because the rook captures on d1 will be
deadly so tonight the d4
Knight captures Bishop captures and now
pawn captures on d3 Bishop captures on
d3 and now Bishop captures on d3 rook
captures on d3 and now c5 and it almost
seems like cousin just won a piece here
and it's game over
well almost I will give it a few seconds
for you to figure out why it's not game
over so I'm sure all of you can see it
and for those of you who are maybe too
lazy as it is Friday for those who who
just want to enjoy the show Bishop to
Bishop to e5 is White's not losing
immediately because now you're attacking
the rook on b8 that's undefended
so rook captures on d3 Bishop captures
on b8 and now c4 locking locking down
that rock on d3 Bushra back to e5 we
have Bishop to c5 and now comes a bishop
rook to be one Queen to d5 we have rook
to b8 this comes with check King to h7
and this is a this is only moved 32 but
it's already the critical moment in the
game here you can see that the queen is
attacking the bishop on e5 and this
Queen I need to can't really move all
that much because now the Queen has to
guard the bishop here and here you would
have to play something like rook to e8
to give more protection the bishop so
you can immobilize your queen but here
sweedler placed a nice trap for Magnus
Carlsen he played Queen to h5 and who
into h5 of course it seems like what are
you doing I mean if I just play f6 then
I'm attacking your bishop
oh you can't move the bishop because the
Queen is under attack but actually this
would be this would be a terrible
mistake if Carson plays something like
this because now white actually has a
forced checkmate in four moves and it's
a very nice checkmate so I will give you
a couple of seconds if you want to
decide if you want to solve this
position for yourself so for those of
you who were able to find it
congratulations you have just a beat in
Magnus Carlsen who have who has
blundered terribly and for those who
just want to enjoy the show
the idea is Queen to a5 check of course
the King has nowhere to go your only
move is g6 and that
you pulled g6 now comes the move you
have to find because I'm sure like all
of you found Queen f5 rock to h8 so this
is the idea now it doesn't matter if you
move the King you can even move you can
move the King and then Queen captures
and f6 will be checkmate and if you
capture the rock then Queen captures on
f6 this comes with check and it doesn't
matter where you move the King then
either Queen to g7 or Queen to 88 will
be checkmate so yeah a very nice
checkmate at that
but after Queen to h5 of course cousin
did not play a move like f6 or anything
like that he played the strongest move
and also a very nice position to for you
to pause the video and find what cousin
played instead of this weird f6 idea and
now it's it's not an easy move to find
so you know feel free to give it even
more time but for those of you who were
able to find this I really congratulate
you now you really shown that you are an
excellent player but for those who just
wanna enjoy the show the move is Queen
to e4 now there's a terrible threat of
Queen to e1 check and then Queen
captures on f2 so how do you how do you
stop this
well the of course Bishop to g5 to g3 is
of course not possible simply rook
captures and you can't capture the rook
because the worship on c5 is spinning
the f2 pawn another thing if you play
something like Bishop to c7 simply
getting your Bishop out of the way so
maybe you can activate pieces then the
real idea of Queen e1 wins the game
immediately for back black after King h2
Queen captures on f2 and now there's
there's really nothing for white to do
here
and another thing after Queen to b4
sweedler played rook to be - the idea is
after Queen to e1 check he wants a DF to
pawn defended but now comes now comes
the real reputation by Carlsen here
cousin played rook to d5 and now you see
that the bishop is under attack there is
no more Queen to a5 or any ideas like
that because the Queen on e4 is also
guarding against that and how do you how
do you defend here how do you defend the
bishop well
one thing you could do you definitely
cannot push a for the the point is still
pinned in the game still are played rook
to e2 now of course you don't want to
capture the bishop that's what that will
be perfectly fine for white about what
you can do is actually Queen to be one
check King to h2 and now I'm sure you
all see the move that wins the game it's
actually f6
and now I mean as funny as it seems a
game from the candidates tournament 2013
is 1 by F 6 that attacks the pinned
piece the bishop cannot move because the
Queen and h5 is undefended so by trying
to set a deadly trap for Carlsen as
wheeler actually fell into inter
Carlson's Carlsen strap so yeah that's
one of the games from round 6 of the
2013 candidates tournament I do hope you
enjoyed it we will show at least one
more game from round 6 but I think will
actually show too because they are very
exciting games and I did prepare one
more thing just not sure if I have it
ready oh no that's that's the photo
elephant let me just give me just one
second ok here we have it this is
something I just wanted to show you this
is a lifetime record of Carlson and
Svidler
to this date until 2018
as you can see sweedler beat Magnus
Carlsen two to one with 12 draws so
sweet ler is one of those players that
actually has a positive record against
Magnus Carlsen in classical games so two
wins force wheeler one win for Carlson
and 12 draws and if you check out only
rapid and exhibition games then Carlson
beats wheeler ten to five with ten draws
but in classical chess it's actually a
swimmer who has the lead I just wanted
to share that information as well so
yeah that was the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Paul
Auster Locke and the Matthew Goss for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
think of for watching and I will see you
soon with another game of or
- from the 2013 candidates tournament
thank you all and I'll see you soon